alors là on va passer à la police donc
la politique en tant que jeunes issus de
la banlieue on les a pas beaucoup
entendus vous exprimer sur le problème
si vous aviez dû brûler des voitures
vous auriez trouvé quel modèle de
voiture je rêverais celle de ma mère
moi j'aurais brûlé une multiple à moi je
la fais là et je pense que même aurait
mené les multiples acquis en somme un
dauphin la lazio dans et par un
stagiaire loisirs d'été tourne elle est
moche mais on est bien dedans c'est la
fin
c'est le cas vous été déçu que sarkozy
n'y aille pas aux antilles bah ouais ben
s'il serait plus bronzé et du coup plus
présente à plus présidentiable quasiment
regarder de villepin est superposé
j'avais beau hein moi non mais même si
je suis pas d'accord tout passe moi je
trouve mais c'est vrai quoi à l'étranger
2020 c'est la classe et voilà ça va
avoir la classe kasper le président
français avec le petit accent français
façon ce sera lui ou sarkozy donc on est
obligé de s'y faire déjà un peu un galet
le pain saisi non mais je n'aime pas
sarkozy alors alors pourquoi parce que
l'hôtel de ville pas bah on est un peu
disco me dire il faut qu'on s'y prenne
un ouais c'est tellement beau j'aimerais
qu'elle gagne kouchner coucher on en est
là les sciences quand ça se fait ce qui
était le mec le plus aimé pourtant c'est
plus élevé mais c'est pas le plus et lui
c'est ça le problème c'est que il faut
absolument pas que tu aies comédiens
côté
avec deux coeurs sont absolument pas
aimer sarkozy ça ça me gonfle terribles
maux moi je l'aimerais bien voyez que
pour ça comme par exemple toi les
artistes sont à gauche à 80 % parce que
c'est pas bien de ta droite
moi je considère la gauche et à droite
comme papa et maman qui tu préfères papa
ou maman
j'aime bien maman parce que c'est des
caresses j'ai des trucs et des fois un
papa il tape un peu sur la table pour
faire le truc donc tu préfères qui bat
mouvement va assez bien que ce soit un
coup papa un comblement ouais moi sans
être artiste
j'exècre sarkozy ah oui c'est à dire
j'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes ce qui
s'est passé quoi un vis-à-vis de sarkozy
malgré tout pas en phase
c'est pas de l'antisarkozisme qu'on fait
nous ont essayé de regarder ce qui fait
depuis deux trois ans effectivement ça
va pas dans le sens de l'intégration
pour les jeunes de banlieue ça va plus
dans le sens de la répression quoi et
messer et c'est pas parce que je suis
artiste que je dis ça je vois juste que
il ya plein de de budget qui étaient
alloués à d'autres choses que la
répression dans les banlieues qui sont
plus là et je connais pas mal la
banlieue en fait et je vois que ça se
les conditions se détériorent et que
c'est aussi par rapport à une politique
qui est menée et jeu il se trouve que
c'est sarkozy quand même qu'ils aient la
tête de proue de cette politique est
donc le mieux le mieux c'est surtout pas
un seul flic en banlieue c'est parce que
je dis mais je sens que c'est exactement
ça non pour sa ktm gamine qui a du mal à
lui envoyer prendre une baguette de pain
comme moi dans des endroits où j'ai
habité tu dis elle va traverser la place
et sait pas si elle va revenir
j'ai dit que c'est pas tout rien par
exemple je ne sais pas tout répressif ou
tout juste sympa keufs sympa on vient
aux gains province
moi c'est pour ça que je dis je le
répète par exemple de responsabiliser
les parents pour qu'ils s'occupent de
leurs enfants je pense pas que ça soit
fasciste c'est comme ça la loi le dit
comme ça les parents sont propriétaires
corps et âme de leurs enfants alors
s'étonner si un pitbull bouffe la gueule
d'une petite fille on va condamner le
propriétaire du but mais j'en arrive et
je suis donc là ça c'est tout à fait
logique tout le monde le comprend non
non latins longtemps non jean marie et
moi mais j'entends parler avec chaleur
et j'entends les mots comme police puis
de bull shit et il est là le problème
c'est quoi cette action positive et si
on a trois mauvaises c'est l'e3 sur
lesquels on veut mettre le prix j'ai
entendu théallet il y avait il y avait
des associations dans les banlieues qui
étaient subventionnés qui envoyait les
jeunes en vacances ou qui les envoyait
dans des familles d'accueil les budgets
ont sauté les budgets en sauter ces
gamins la caisse qui font le mercredi
après midi
il galère dans les halls qu'est ce qu'on
vient de leur interdire de l'énergie
dans les halls donc où il est leur
espace de liberté star que on leur
enlève les petits et les petits cadeaux
les petits bonbons et ensuite on leur
enlève les endroits où ils peuvent au
moins se voir discuter quoi juste un
espace privilégié pour évidemment des
problèmes dans les halls
il ya des gens qui arrivent pas à dormir
parce que les gamins ils parlent dans
les eaux jusqu'à minuit 1h du mat
mais c'est pas la majorité des lots et
hall de banlieue sauf que c'est ce que
c'est le discours de sarkozy ça veut
dire tous les gamins maintenant sont
dans les halls et font du bruit les gens
responsables n'arrive pas à dormir donc
interdisons les halls aux jeunes les
données de l'espionnage et donnant du
travail enfin prenons les cv acceptons
les donnons leur du travail égal est
rompue dans les halls pas qu'il faut se
lever le lendemain matin
voilà
alors
et tout à l'heure j'ai entendu un
président heureux parce que je vais vous
risquez de passer pour le fashion sphère
non je te connais tu n'es pas et donc
dans ma rue moi et je sais pas si vous
le faites dans votre rue mais moi dans
ma rue il n'ya pas un mec qui traînent
par terre que je ne vais pas voir et qui
je demande qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour lui et de quoi il a besoin
jean-marie ce que chacun d'entre nous
devraient faire mais seulement quand un
pays tout entier est occupée c'est
beaucoup plus divisés n'ont pas pu
difficilement les amis vachement de côté
c'est bien ça fait quand même c'est le
problème n'est pas d'aujourd'hui ça fait
des années que c'est comme ça j'ai déjà
sauter avant leur kehoe dans lesquelles
toute entière pas eu d il ya eu des
émeutes qui sont pas l'équivalent de ça
et mitterrand est venu il semble dans
les cités il avait fait un voyage c'est
parce que la cité des 4000 à la
courneuve à la courneuve il est allé et
il a dit ouais ça ça on va raser ça on
va raser ça on va raser ça va changer il
y avait les caméras c'était il ya vingt
ans et elles sont restées et je pense
que l'effet zidane a fait que tout ça ça
a pu et d'angré n'est encore un petit
peu parce qu'en 90 en idf c'est bon on
marque des buts
donc c'est génial zidane président donc
les arabes ça va tout va bien les mecs
de cités ça va il s'en sortent et en
fait ça a permis mais sinon les émeutes
a aurait dû exploser il ya encore il ya
six ans a normalement et il ya autre
chose que j'ai que que j'ai entendu que
il ya des jeunes qui ont le choix entre
vendre du shit ou bien aller travailler
et y en a qui préfèrent aller vendre du
shit et alors ça vraiment non ça a
vraiment le vent furieux
c'est un vrai choix malheureusement un
moment c'est vrai qu'ils vont vendus
soit des cépages en 55 ans mia mont amba
soi mais la question est posée qu'à un
moment donné
le jeune qui est dans deux eaux va
effectivement lui faire cette
proposition et si jamais il accepte et
ben il va après avoir du mal à les
gratter mais la première proposition
jean-marie la première proposition me
suis moi te couper elle vient quand même
du jeune qui envoie son cv et qu'on lui
dit non donc la proposition après du
dealer de shit elle vient après et je
veux finir sur la dernière chose à
l'écran cette image nous garder la
meilleure
sion est ce qu'il faut faire à partir de
maintenant c'est faut qu'on aille voter
il faut qu'on aille tous voté et que ça
sera le meilleur moyen pour avoir des
gens qui nous représenteront et se faire
écouter il fallait
on est d'accord
si on veut faire quelque chose ici pour
que les jeunes s'inscrit pour 2007 moi
je pense que chacun d'entre nous
devraient essayer de s'occuper de son
prochain et si il y en a seulement deux
ou trois par rue
eh ben on règle vraiment beaucoup de
problème donc que tu te gamme de tons
voisins et ben tu fais tout simplement
pas quinze mille morts de la solitude
pas morts de la canicule on sait cours
et sont pas morts de la canicule les
vieux sont morts de la solitude parce
que leurs voisins de palier ne
s'occupait pas de la vieille personne
qui est à côté d'eux bien évidemment
mais
si tu voyais les gens qui sont vraiment
détruit en bas de chez toi tu méprises
un mec comme sarkozy par exemple parce
que c'est
il est ici parce que 6 1 mais il paraît
simple et schmoll du hunan board pas
vous vous gueulez après quelqu'un qui
regarde longueur sur un mec qu'on gagne
sur un mec qui donc a coupé les budgets
pour aider tous les problèmes de
quartier comme eric en a parlé de mesure
il met sur le jeu lui c'est le même mec
qui fait des qui fait des lois pour pour
alléger l'impôt sur la grosse fortune
six des précieux l'impôt sur les grosses
fortunes résoudre voiselle padfone ua
est très bien mais une finale dans chez
nous sur ce qui se passe chez nous et
autres chaussures les parents n'ont pas
blâmer les parents n'en est qu'une
moitié mais de blâmer les parents et
leur dire ce sont les parents qui sont
responsables je trouve ça scandaleux
eh ben c'est le temps qu'il a manqué
justement qu'à 80 j'étais encore au
quartier aujourd'hui c'est pas elle qui
me bloque répondu je suis situé à elle
c'est ma mère qui te parle quasiment pas
résister et à la 87ème quand vous êtes
maman et ses deux soeurs ne laissera pas
sortir deux heures parce que je suis pas
de la génération je sais pas la
génération d'aujourd'hui mais je suis
sorti je suis sorti du quartier mais tu
vas dans les quartiers et les corrigés
lundi 7 heures de l'après midi on se dit
que même si les parents ont eux mêmes
été abandonnés par leurs parents
le problème quand même bien de la racine
en robes l'analyseur le prennent bien de
ces mecs qu'on construit ces espèces
d'immondices d'horreur total de l'ours
russe les grains de demander alors ils
sont restés
des parents c'est le problème c'est que
simplement quant à d espèce de truc qui
se dégradent d'un seul gilles son bras
les adresses y a pas de boulot et 55 ans
sont classés pas les parents qu'on ait
cette aide reste là il est là aussi le
problème
allons tous voter nommé par votre
discours il est il est il englobe
absolument tout alors que ça n'est pas
vrai qu'est ce qui n'est pas vrai c'est
à dire qu'il ya une partie comme par
exemple en corse
si tu me dis que tous les corps sont des
[ __ ] non mais par contre il ya dieter
qui ne veulent que tu es qui sont des
[ __ ]
c'est tout l'accord de shit par exemple
et ils n'ont pas tous vendeurs de ramsey
y en a